all right Peter there it is there's the
scarf there's a battle scar how do you
think I think it looks settled but it
looks like it was really bad at what
point it was my forehead was literally
split open I'm not exaggerating like
that that wide I could feel the plastic
surgeon pulling my skin over to stitch
it out stuff was there a lot of blood
how much there was a ton of London it
looked like a murder scene when I went
to happen it just started pouring out I
was the kind of like DS I didn't feel it
at all to be honest my endorphins are
just like firing and and then everyone
just rushes over and you know puts their
hand on in I end up finding out later on
how bad it was I see the first picture I
was like oh my god like I'll never look
the same again and the plastic surgeon
took care of me can did a good job down
still that handsome face your good story
to tell him didn't win you points with
the ladies like we did like oh he's good
yeah injured I definitely remember the
first time I saw the ladies because it
was I this happened the day before they
even got to where we were at and then
the next day I have a date and it didn't
stop anything slow anything down which
is cool but I walk up and I see him for
the first time in there just a guy
called some crazy story like I fought a
puma off like in the jungle but kind of
like make it sound better but now they
took good care of me so it was literally
just a glass to the head it was a golf
cart there's a glass in my forehead you
just tripped I didn't trip I just sat
into the golf cart bang my head reacted
smash the glass in my forehead and what
a trajectory so did that give you
clarity on your feelings for the win I
mean was it like did you pin here I know
it all I understand it all did you see
how they reacted and that was a bit
telling how much does it affect the
season and and how things end up
actually guys it does kind of it it's
not just like that one episode it does
kind of play a role in a little bit
later on in season which is kind of cool
I'm not gonna let spoil it but it's
actually kind of cool and I don't know
it's just you know I def the girls
definitely took care of me it definitely
kind of felt bad about it but I wasn't
gonna let this you know slow down my
journey to you know fine whatever they
wanted and it's all I got I got a battle
scar now chicks dig scars so I'm chillin
did you
what you really wanted you know I'm
gonna give you some rapid fires okay
what are worse your literal scar or your
emotional scars a fact you toss a 50/50
to be completely honest yeah sure I get
broken possibly but not in a way that
maybe possibly okay yeah sounds like yes
okay yeah are you hurt worse than when
Hannah broke up with you it's it's uh no
okay all right that was making decisions
for my heart because I know there's
still something there and I would do
anything for for a relationship and what
was it like when Hannah returns because
she does come back what do you guys get
out of that is that a clear ending for
you too
what was it like that was unexpected for
me I did not know what she was coming
that first night and she shows up opens
that door I didn't even realize was her
at first and then I noticed it's her
she's kind of walking closer or out of
the car and you know I thought I
genuinely thought when I decided yeah
it'll be the bachelor that I was in a
spot where I could do that and I I was
ready and I'd moved on I really did
think that she shows up that first night
and I start to question that and this
real emotions kind of come up and it was
all real it was all there was a real
relationship we had been and she really
broke your heart yeah she did but yeah
you guys will just have to see what
happens when I'm not to say it's
extremely crazy what would you say if I
I asked you to come be part of that
Alison so do we get an ending for you
too because if we're doing a math on how
much she was filming Dancing with the
Stars there's no way she was on your
whole season of The Bachelor there's
just not everyone thinks that but I mean
he's not filming the entire week maybe
the locations weren't so far from LA so
I don't know everyone thinks it's not
possible and I get that but um so were
you and Hanna together right now
[Laughter]
more rapid-firing how much do you cry a
lot yeah that was yeah a lot it was
definitely it was the most amazing
experience of my life but the toughest
and I had such an insane such an amazing
group of women that I felt and I fell
for multiple people I did you fall in
love with multiple people
I fell for multiple people and I that
was tough for me it was tough for me
kind of giving my heart to different
people and you know for sure I remember
the last like two weeks Oh last week I
was the hardest of my life like for sure
the heart the last week was the hearts
week my life and never thought never
pictured it kind of going that way never
imagined it kind of feeling that way or
ending them ending that way but I'm
stronger for it how did it end Peter
crazy it's I am I am I am I can say I am
very happy with everything I did and I'm
excited that there's a reason that no
one's gonna find out the onion and I'm
excited about that you think no one will
find out the ending on this one yeah why
I told you anyway
are you engaged right now can't ask you
that I can say that I am happy okay are
you in love right now you're good but I
can say I'm happy do you say I love you
to multiple women no maybe you keep some
of those feelings hidden
Peter flies in and he's looking so
freakin delicious like I just want to
wake him up and down how much sex do you
have okay
believe it or not I know no one thinks
I'm very private with my intimate life
no one think I know no one thinks I did
it i but if you look back I never said
anything about the windmill that was not
one word came out of my mouth about that
that's truth yeah and it's all good but
I'm comfortable talking about it
but it's I like to keep that stuff
private I do do you join the mile-high
club you're acting like I haven't
already maybe I don't know on Hannah's
season the JED girlfriend thing was
quite a scandal just your season up the
scandal auntie well we see something is
oh my god
I don't think so no no okay no that's a
good thing right thank God you know yeah
um you told me before you started
filming that your greatest fear and all
this was being fooled do you get fooled
are you betrayed in any way I I wouldn't
use the word betrayed I definitely had
this moments that I had relationships it
took me a little bit longer to truly
find out that I guess complete truth of
what we had or where we were for sure
not not portrayed well how is night one
I mean why we were there right before
you started filming you were so excited
but nervous how does a night one go over
although there's a lot of flight
attendants there are a lot of questions
yeah that was no that was cute
night one was amazing that was I
remember standing there with Chris I
show up and he's waiting it's just like
it was very surreal for me because I've
been a fan of the show for so long and I
remember that night and everyone you
love that night it's just a fun night
and I'm like paint I'm The Bachelor and
how like this is crazy and they're about
to come meet me just insane feeling of
gratitude knowing what was about to
happen it's a journey that I was so
excited for it was literally about to
take off and I was nervous like no other
I felt my heart was like gonna come out
of my chest but that first limo came
that door opened then I'll call again
did you feel yourself quickly connecting
with a couple of people did women stand
to that night of course yeah I
definitely had that that that instant
you know chemistry in connection with a
couple but I wanted to do a good job of
not letting that close me off from
relationships that started off a little
bit slower and that was some advice I
got from some of the previous bachelors
and I wanted really to take that to
heart and I'm happy I did did you get
engaged to a flight attendant can I
follow my dad's lead we will see alright
last question Chris did an interview
with us this weekend straight-up said
Victoria is the villain so what can you
tell us about what happens with Victoria
I love Victoria she's an amazing person
she really is I understand why Greg
Chris said that I get that but I want
everyone all the viewers just to watch
and come up with their own opinion about
her don't prejudge on some stuff that
you've been hearing she's an amazing
person there's a lot of endearing
qualities that she has and I definitely
could say I learned a lot from her and
it was very grateful for her coming on
the show I don't want to give give away
what I can't say some guys sound like
constant thinking like but no like I
feel like she she's an amazing person
and I hear the stuff that's been talked
about but I know her she's amazing okay
so you're defending her a little bit
yeah of course okay last questions for
you
we're we have a whole Hispanic heritage
side of our website and as it's been
pointed out you are only the second lead
ever with some Hispanic heritage here on
The Bachelor how does that feel for you
do we see anything about your culture
this season your your family's past and
how do they feel about it yeah that's
pretty cool um you do for sure you see a
lot of my Cuban roots to come out and
literally from the probably first
episode and it's just kind of there's
definitely a theme I guess I'd like the
whole Hispanic side throughout the show
I'm not gonna lie that's cool and I love
that I love sharing that and my family
plays a big role in it too and there's
you know my biggest supporter so I love
that yeah alright he flew the friendly
skies for bachelor bachelor for you
thank you
[Music]